well there's a dunkaroo song here should  we try and sing it in 1993's uh 1993 don  cruz released a song during one of his  commercials that went let's do it lane  for lane okay like a zapper go on i'll  follow you go on my name is sydney i'm  an awesome hunk  i'll start again my name is sydney i'm  an awesome hunk got a wacky snack you  don't just eat you dunk cookies on the  one side crushes on the other the creamy  taste will drive you wild let's have  another dunkaroo sucka roost you don't  just eat dunkarvoo frosting light  chocolate vanilla yummy cookies too  tastes so good with a glass of moo  dunker rose duncan rose  all right well should we try one yeah we  could have been wrappers we're doing  good  chairs  you know duncan the whole thing of it  all right fair enough look at that  maine looks like alfalfa  ah  not bad not bad  harmonize with me and hold me back all  through the night you're shining bright  i'm your boy  [Music]